well cosmetic surgeries on the rise
across the country especially among gen
Z and not all the procedures are the
traditional type if you can uh call any
cosmetic surgery traditional this new
generation is uh it's getting Innovative
often in the most grotesque ways
imaginable so for instance one of the
hotest procedures on the market is
called uh kop pigmentation which along
with being a great Scrabble word that I
think I pronounced correctly actually is
also a surgery to change the color of
your eyes New York Post reports quote
don't want to be a brown-eyed girl
anymore if you're not afraid of the
risks including go going blind iris
color changing surgery the latest
procedure to go viral online might be
for you the process known as kerop
pigmentation involves using a laser to
create a tunnel in superficial cornea in
order to place pigment but experts are
warning it could lead to many terrifying
conditions including blindness not to
mention it's not approved for cosmetic
use